on vous l'a promis hier nous avons
rencontré phia ménard une grande artiste
de cirque auquel le festival spring rend
hommage à travers une rétrospective
rencontre c'est vrai qu'on se dit
toujours une introspectif c'est un peu
un drôle d'endroit vous avez déjà fait
du chemin ou alors qu'on se dit la
rétrospective c'est quand vous êtes mort
le coeur j'ai pas l'impression d'être
morte
de plus tôt la rétrospective c'est
plutôt du coup joyeux c'est à dire que
on propose aux spectateurs de voir un
ensemble d'oeuvres peut-être ce qui est
le plus joyeux pour moi c'est de ces
d'avoir voulu dire toujours c'est c'est
pas le résultat qui m'intéresse mais ces
processus cheminement ouais donc quelque
part c'est d'offrir au spectateur la
possibilité pour un cheminement et
surtout de le vivre
et puis à ses fins de l'expérience belle
d'hier un certain sens c'est l'histoire
de belles de d'hier oui vallières visite
le mythe du prince charmant mais un peu
trash quand même oui on lui laisse pas
tellement de place en fait on s'aperçoit
qu'il a pris la place depuis tellement
longtemps qu'on a envie de lui dire bon
un peu à nous donc c'est un peu ce cette
base j'ai simplement demandé à ses cinq
femmes de ranger l'humanité alors ça
peut paraître comme ça absolument
prétentieux et est fou mais c'est ce
qu'elles font elles rangent l'humanité
devant vous sur scène elle veut leur
engin une sorte d' en pire en pire voilà
un empire des hommes un empire du
patriarcat institué et ont été de dire
voilà
je oui j'aime les femmes et c'est un
hommage rendu aux femmes plus que tout
et à leur combat au fait qu'elles
acceptent de continuer à faire des
enfants alors que ce monde-là n'est pas
forcément si simple une belle oeuvre à
découvrir phia ménard bellepierre mais
aussi les autres pièces notamment ce
week-end vendredi et samedi belle d'hier
à la brèche ici et puis le spectacle ira
aussi à hérouville merci nous avons reçu
merci à vous
owen cambell guitariste australien
spécialiste du slide et andy mckee
guitariste américain ry spécialiste du
tapping deux prodiges de la guitare en
concert au normandy à saint lô c'est
samedi soir
ce à ses amis sa paperasse à ses amis
mais c'est pas un vif alors je sais pas
où il allait me charger à l'andi faut
parler de me charger mais moi toi ça ses
amis c'est pas ça s'est passé pas c'est
pas me passer ainsi sa marche pas
oui
c'est 100 et magenta portes s'ouvrent
majeur toute la course
vous n'allez pas échapper à la question
me fire pourquoi comment le vif à jeurre
tout simplement parce que c'est un ami
qu'un accord qui n'existe pas voilà la
mi mineur mi bémol majeur n'existe pas
ce nom est venu parce qu'on a joué un
soir très fatigué et du coup ont joué
totalement faux du mixage heures
objet entendu du reggae j'ai entendu du
fils de rap et vous mélanger les styles
c'est ça voilà c'est à peu près ça on
essaye de faire à la chanson au sens
large
donc c'est ça peut être festif ça peut
être réglé ça peut être swingue ça peut
être une balade ça peut être aussi rock
se rentrer dedans et puis de faire
découvrir un petit peu voilà de
différents horizons
vous êtes rencontrés
bah en fait de son copain d'enfance ils
sont quasiment des ensembles de
coutainville
et du coup moi je suis arrivé ici sur
coudun après je connaissais paul on a
commencé à jouer ensemble dans un boeuf
comme ça donc c'est la manche
voilà voilà et puis bas du dos est venu
nous rejoindre comme ça par hasard dans
un bar et puis on a commencé mi majeur à
trois au départ en fait on est six
aujourd'hui on a fait des bébés quoi
mais pas art
e